okay bet says um it's your boy
psychobabble and you know I know the
pictures bigger don't worry we're just
playing this game called
some okra some luckily it's similar it's
a basically fine split the phone some
[ __ ] some are again I don't know if I
get a house do this I press up again you
know I locked this thing oh [ __ ]
Toby's birthday what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to know that all one's eight
zero one eight zero seven she's
beautiful
hey baby I think we got plenty of batter
what is this do find Anna okay
can I help you gallery yes
[Music]
all right guys
except we gotta come find her I think
it's a menu yeah
System Restore what the [ __ ] is this I
don't ask for this it's got plenty of
battery but she got shitty [ __ ] high
five that's all I gotta say that's
taking about ten years
okay we gotta find this [ __ ] vlogger
[Music]
Greg what what the [ __ ] okay okay
first vlog
uh-huh
so you think your youtuber
yeah yeah what are you doing a lot of
[ __ ] video I was thinking they
probably I think all [ __ ] day say
chats let's go old style
let's go Merv I guess August 3rd hey you
still with your boyfriend come on man
just a scam people are talking have you
consider the things you say might come
off as great me offline okay you're
[ __ ] Merv the perv okay hello Hannah
and these cookies need to pass to you so
I thought please told you tiny shells
during the speech foods only a box then
why can't you finish it didn't wanna
bring it awesome sure Nana
okay so then two days later we're like
yeah I changed the front you there mom
all I asked for some space so you only
want to say me when you need something
most pretty pretty that's not true mom
why are you avoiding me I am NOT then
let me come over I am eze they took her
strange is not what the [ __ ] suppose
you'd be supportive from my decision
that's all supportive you say as if I
never do anything for you I paid your
rent when he took three months off to a
silly South hop course tell me it's
gonna be good for you what do you have
to show at the end I'll ask you see your
mother once in a while that difficult
fine days later I'm penny is coming over
soon I hope you're keeping your promise
yeah I can make it I'll call you on
wedding where I heard what happened
maybe it's time you listen to me for
once and let it go the world is not run
by silly mantras your sense of purpose
material world you work it paid you have
that already so why you so desperate
threw away you think anyone lost through
so this bridge she quit like on August
9th oh holy [ __ ] what if and penny has
mister accompany you there
[ __ ] this [ __ ] thing is going crazy
answer me
we just want to drown everything out for
a bit it's just every possible shitty
thing that could happen happened at the
same time and it sucks I know you're
worried okay okay
later you're like hey every talk to aunt
penny hey mom yeah I don't want to work
at a PR firm said what's on different
try and help you out maybe listen she
consoled the pet store not the same I'm
grateful there's a point mat so much is
happening you know I did this because I
love you right guys wrong yeah love you
too mom
hello hello okay so the 13th or she's
like [ __ ] gone
I haven't losses on the 12th missile
emeth so I'm like the 12th she [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's late babe eggs way back
happened again
oh damn what's the meanest again how
late can someone be for a teammate in
half an hour
and now that'd be editor-in-chief
trucked everything [ __ ] yeah now I watch
do you want me to check my place she
can't find her watch you lose your head
if it wasn't attached vortex club what
is that oh yeah yeah there we go that
bar okay she's an application so whose
[ __ ] Greg wasn't feeling it so she think
I got him Greg in acting so I named
Victor what it
what what is this a hack
so she caught guard doing something mess
is corrupted
second words in the correct order to
rebuild the message so no no so I took
his phone and showed it to him way god
I'm bets he denied it to phone to his
phone it's wrong I know I'm not the
jealous type
but it was just staring mr. Kamin I just
looked um she's face he's a nerve to
accuse me buddy he yelled at me he told
me to leave that's the end of it
so what do you say is gonna do about it
he didn't do anything listening okay all
right now right Greg pick up wait I just
want to see when that thing was I think
I was [ __ ] like July [ __ ] it took
like she didn't talk to Ashley in like
10 years
July 31st okay yeah all go [ __ ] back
here August 1st to the next day pick up
my calls place its corrupted you went
out blind wait you are the one that went
out of line
perfect we're good we are [ __ ] gut
here's the one that wouldn't have line
when you went through my property I
might Matt just appointed holy [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] cheater
two days later nothing four days later
nothing good for that he's like where
the [ __ ] are you next day hear me out
[Music]
when you're ready
that week okay give you space that is
like one of the weirdest voice-acting
snips I've ever heard didn't come in
here or on earth are you was that how is
that it's Greg
[Music]
I'm not who you think I am baby some
sort of trick to stop him reaching you
better than Miss Anna I'm not anti betch
I'm not Anna she lost her phone
this is Weis pharmacy voice or wise who
is this [ __ ] Greg Greg Greg Greg Greg
Greg Greg you're telling me Greg yeah I
get it why he held out their phone if I
was left on my doorstep
[Music]
I think she's in danger huh yeah okay of
Court or something weird send me that
video well what a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
the [ __ ] is it
at the one [ __ ] diary where'd he go
yeah okay much [ __ ] some kind of suit
jokes I can always if you disobey and I
swear to God
looks like it the light in itself the
[ __ ] is going up [ __ ] saved
I got games named after me get away from
me
[Music]
exceptions bad [ __ ]
creaking I always suck at typing
emails what's going on with the email oh
[ __ ] when I was seven hey [ __ ] was
Tony's birthday again
[ __ ] they told me in the beginning it
would be in a [ __ ] is Tony mr. Tony mr.
Tony
oh [ __ ] is Tony goddamn it
[Music]
Gregor she mom the very last call was to
Patrick Lehman and that was like [ __ ]
today
the [ __ ] says
forgot my password who send anything to
her email [ __ ]
anyway Tony whoa mama
now you got that cat I got image
corrupted build the fragments in the
correct order
that's [ __ ] weird okay hey get off huh
Tubby's birthday coffee coffee ice cream
the [ __ ] is Toby
oh you got you can't cover anything up
cool
raise Tony's birthday [ __ ] his timing
[ __ ]
oh holy [ __ ] okay there we go
Harry cop eyes [ __ ]
there we go that must be Tony
okay July 18th it's 6:18
get the [ __ ] out of here now taro sex 18
7 0 7 18 no I [ __ ] did it
but
it was a [ __ ] Stickles again tough
tubby
except right what's your mom's maiden
name [ __ ]
Hardy
come on come on come on
[Music]
what's your favorite we would [ __ ]
it's paying her [ __ ] blog but let me
just check any [ __ ] movie any [ __ ]
movie okay all [ __ ] up blogger there
you go
surfer
history
and you got the new operating system
let's get a spark and just see what the
[ __ ] can I sign in
if you sit on hey kid hey hey there
I got a romantic proposition for you
what is it if you sit on my face I will
eat my way through your heart what a guy
they really don't make them right are
the Starling oh my god
just a gentleman how many love to do
dinners would it take to turn your
bedroom into an acrobats Jim hey talk to
you here know a Fred Fred Fred sit ya
know ya know what are your monday
parties movies yoga happy hour and we're
sponsor come here next week none of the
above
I've recently picked up breathing
otherwise look new movie what's her
favorite movie meet up three years ago
what right
three years ago so this guy doesn't work
works at tea love deaf [ __ ] she almost
set the [ __ ] movie like your big
banks would eat some cookie dough
together excuse me what I mean you want
to go have some time together you there
what the [ __ ] now you all right there
senior exec hey you know huh yeah a cat
that's to their pokémons um game boy
what the [ __ ] I can't [ __ ] sex look
at travel your name should be Wonder
Woman get it come on not even a petty
lout Wow
restoration is so easy I'm Taylor and
the [ __ ] is that
yes
[Music]
I said if I can go through it
[Music]
I didn't into that's a [ __ ] lie I
married one god I'll do return the fan
yes if you know where she is baby
[Music]
max point stole my bike like get the
[ __ ] out of here okay okay come on
Taylor Pereira the [ __ ] it here
now it's cool now whoa
yes Stephanie holy [ __ ] start Shannon
that bad but let's do this
[Music]
the [ __ ] you want Taylor get the [ __ ]
out of here
what
[Music]
everyone here sucks yeah baby Stephanie
get the [ __ ] at it
Stephon it oh my god
[Music]
I know what a man
hey don't see people out the [ __ ]
talk that's why you made them baby
that's Stephanie you're gonna take
control of your destiny see I'm trying
to help Anna but I'm also along the
journey
helping Stephanie okay yes um bad things
do happen Stephanie so get your [ __ ]
together
okay
to forget here
[Music]
get the [ __ ] out of here obviously this
is always a time okay I can't get the
jabber yet thinking went through all
vlogger
[Music]
[ __ ] slow as [ __ ] but dog okay
are so ass
Harrison can
I'd like to sign in get the [ __ ] out of
here chat fun even good email that's
what happens
they put your school night would do it
again she wants to become a vet now get
the [ __ ] outta here
Jim Farraday where are those data
packets I asked for Anna it's a million
time I look for anything are you going
[ __ ] nuts
don't [ __ ] his Faraday same thing you
noticed that you're picking a lot of
that you ever think for nature
what the [ __ ] has picked up tech issue
skin
applesauce fresh and crispy some layers
for texturing rich it's a picture stack
of them the right thing the [ __ ] is this
spark
[Music]
okay don't forget the [ __ ] out of here
her husband
now get the [ __ ] out
tailor what the [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] I throw it me just
[ __ ] nuts then I go through all the
cameras pictures I don't think I did
tobei there tan come on I need some
details possession [ __ ] there's a tough
one
okay
[Music]
[Music]
it's fun [ __ ] hard okay okay we had
this [ __ ] make sense these are the
roughest ones let's do this one I fancy
that one so we'll [ __ ] flip it [ __ ]
it so that's gonna [ __ ] up that side
I have to do one too because there's no
other way to get that corner I don't
think
holy [ __ ] that stuff
any [ __ ] movies movies I'm looking
for movies they got ammo by that
passion fruit Tobias
that's [ __ ] you doing okay
sake jumping [ __ ] that job I'm
[ __ ] busy
what's your favorite movie
what's your favorite movie
[Music]
she says she says please someone tell me
her favorite movie
[Music]
oh yeah exactly it's make a curry
I'm disagreement
trying to get [ __ ] into jabber
[Music]
let's do this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah we got them
is that me
this kind of definitely knows her anyway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay baby yeah yeah yeah
hunting and evading Gondo Oh chicken
Takato
Hotel painting cat important thing in
game taking don't want you thinking
Devon take him back in the-- Topanga is
still done thinking they actually what
the [ __ ] is removing hello hey Ashley
what the [ __ ] going on [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on [ __ ]
no how's it
I can't guarantee that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
audio land uh-oh
[Music]
holy [ __ ] so I walked up to her played
it cool pretend to ask for a card and
stuff right turns out that's gank but I
stuff for other people
I didn't realize a job like that even
existed sounds kind of lame did you
think sucks the fun out of shopping like
what if you want to return something you
return it to them or they will return it
on your behalf
shopping is pretty straightforward why
would anyone complicate things
[Music]
maybe she don't
[Music]
you oh [ __ ] a dog's burp yes
we're [ __ ] in [ __ ] come on
any dogs purpose where an muchachos [ __ ]
yeah okay taste me Ferriday safety takes
me a good day three months ago what are
my [ __ ] goals unlock jammer I'm mo
make sure actually never finds out about
Ana's disappearance find Ana
whoa
this [ __ ] ain't this [ __ ] ain't real hey
des
how the [ __ ] is that possible
[Music]
no Fallon have a death oh my god
oh my god
can't fit my face spring right
and I was doing this hello it hurt yeah
oh [ __ ]
can I have this I try cascade bang think
I got a laid Joey thing
[Music]
[Music]
what what the [ __ ] is all this
new vlog available wait so what the [ __ ]
was that gallery thing well now I got
all the jabber pictures I forgot who is
this Santa Monica now get the [ __ ] away
from me all right oh wait whoa what the
[ __ ] was that
what the [ __ ] is this big thing now what
do you want baby
[Music]
[Music]
wait I wearing in that photo No
[Music]
[Music]
I can't find it
okay
Gregg holy [ __ ]
[Music]
okay I think my cars to get a university
and to register
[Music]
and I guessed
let's let a minute let's let him in the
[ __ ] is his full name again I think it's
Greg summers right
quick summers yeah okay
[Music]
Craig summers [ __ ] Greg Sommers
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
[ __ ] outta here shouts sand sound like
that's just counting your send it yeah
yeah yeah oh honey honey you're my honey
boo boo oh you're my honey boo boo boo
you're my honey bail bail
yeah yeah Holden is it
I don't give me ain't got dumped and
what not happening there's someone
inside shuffling [ __ ] break down that
door do it be very careful
something's wrong there was this voice
or a sound [ __ ] I'm recording this
[Music]
tubby
[Music]
he's a master stuff all over for to
focus that voice
[Music]
did your hair batch
[Music]
find the source of the jabber post still
warm
okay how do you do them this much and
talk texting so much
[Music]
[ __ ] do that you're gonna cancel that
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is a cat that [ __ ] you
better [ __ ] it you activate it you
[Music]
better hurry up alright you say [ __ ]
all right applesauce so big Tobias
get the [ __ ] back
[Music]
Annagh
in a sauce Anna sauce apple
[ __ ] 46 us experienced let me addy
you all
right
[Music]
chase
die cat a aunt
[Music]
I'm trying to can I take like this yeah
now
better Bebek yes yes
laughs
boss
and of course baby
[Music]
Chad's yeah go [ __ ] yourself
hello this is an automated police
emergency response your call is
important to us damn straight it's
important sorry
all of our operators are currently busy
if there is an immediate danger please
press 1 if you wish to report a non
immediate crime please state your
emergency for murders or manslaughter
press 1 for aggravated assault or
battery press 2 for domestic
disturbances press 3 please hold while
we transfer you to one of our operators
so then I take the steroids for sure
[Music]
your call is important to us please hold
oh my god what is going on with this
whole thing music you think you know
somebody [ __ ] sad it's sad your call
is important to us please hold
yeah you [ __ ] hold okay some teddy
[ __ ]
[Music]
your call is important to us please hold
I don't think they're ever gonna
actually come
[Music]
nothing
[ __ ] his honor yo yo are you safe no
[Music]
Ranma
yeah they found her death
Danah
you need to turn it out
do it up English plays I guess
yeah maestro says that's why it's all
right back
though it is talking here
[ __ ] flying I am Anna
hi this is Anna
pick on stuff okay
tell me who you are thank you remember
Bebek cannot I remember yeah and me
yeah you'll find me and
well fine fine
if not
all right otherwise I guess huh because
I look at that have a good one yeah have
a good one
yeah say on the next one